well if you are between 65 and 69 years
old you've probably heard
you are now next in line to get the
vaccine and sure enough many of you
lined up quite early today hoping to get
your turn
madison kimbrough joining us live from
cashman center
that's one of the locations that is
offering walk-ins madison you heard some
people lining up
as early as 3 a.m just to get a place in
line
yes and 500 doses were distributed this
morning here at cashman center for
walk-ins
and those doses went very quickly
let me take a chance and come down here
and as it turned out
i'm getting in so it's i'm really really
happy
a busy friday at the vaccination sites
around the valley those 65 and older
took full advantage of the opportunity
to get their coven 19 vaccine
many not concerned about the long wait
i'm hoping it's not going to be too long
but
waited in longer lines trying to vote at
cashman center those who were not early
risers didn't get their chance at the
500 doses for walk-ins so they tried
their luck at desert pines high school
this place had 300 catchment had five
so i got up and put some clothes on and
waited on the clock because i didn't
know what to
offer but at desert pines the 300
capacity limit for doses tapped out
around 12 30 this afternoon
luckily for these two it was mission
accomplished as they both were able to
get their first dose today
you have to take care all around it's
just this is not a solitary issue
it involves everybody around you i can't
wait to get out i want to be able to go
places and see things
and for those 65 and older and also
utility workers appointments will be
accepted on february 24th and 25th
at veterans memorial community center
that's off of pavilion center and ulta
and then also at the centennial hills
active adult center
off of buffalo and 95 we'll of course
have all this information up on our
website
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now